Dresden lies on the river Elbe it's a
grand City with imposing buildings from
the Renaissance and Baroque periods as
well as the 19th century much of the
architecture has an Italian touch
Dresden is known as Florence on the Elbe
twists net and a window pockets touch
Dresden has a wonderful historic center
with amazing museums the state art
collections are among the world's
greatest distraction concern and we have
a marvelous Opera House toilet oppa
momma dezember oppa
it was designed by God leads Empire and
opened in 1841 nearby is the glorious
baroque Church of Our Lady the faux
incursion
the eighteenth-century original was
destroyed in the Second World War it was
recently rebuilt almost from scratch and
reconsecrated in 2005 the Church of Our
Lady can be considered the center of the
city with ADIZ Dresden has once again
become a metropolis after the ravages of
the war this mural dating back to 1907
depicts the rulers of Saxony over the
previous eight centuries this is al
ghostess the strong he was a great
collector of art and commissioned many
grand buildings including fits finger
Palace the architect described it as a
kind of Roman theatre
I'm singer hails from the most glorious
period of Dresden's history in the 18th
century Augustus the strong who is not
only elector of Saxony but also king of
Poland built its finger as a grand space
in which to demonstrate and dramatize
his power and great festivities a
collection of old masters is housed in
the palace it comprises 3,000 works a
highlight is Raphael's Sistine Madonna
from 1512 another great museum is the
IVA Tina
it's devoted to art from the Romantic
era to the present day
nextdoor is a gallery that hosts special
exhibitions the show there right now is
called paradise on earth
Flemish landscape painting from heigl to
Rubens with works drawn from Dresden's
own collections the city of Dresden is
home to one of the oldest and most
comprehensive collections of Italian
Dutch French German and Spanish painting
from the 16th century onwards Dresden
also has an edgy cool side across the
over in Newtown cafes design workshops
clubs and art galleries are springing up
here there are all kinds of interesting
things to be discovered off the streets
in inner courtyards the outer Newtown
district was always where ordinary
people lived the apartments were small
and simple rents below it strong mobs of
students and young creative people they
don't want to live in the concrete
housing projects in downtown there
aren't any apartments so this has become
the cool part of town zenith tickle deny
ignition stunt
but there's competition downtown an old
power station as being turned into an
Arts Center it's set to open next month
the state operetta will have a new home
here
when you study music has always been
very important for Dresden it was
already a musical metropolis under the
electors and kings and throughout the
bourgeois and Protestant period Dresden
is an absolute treasure trove and
definitely worth a visit
you